and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review John greatest movie
you've ever seen in my life I come from
the planet spoilers here's this guy
named John Carter oh my god they made a
movie about the terminator kid maybe
before he turned into that guy who yells
at people for walking into the shot oh
this time he's traveling to Mars so I'm
this planet he can apparently breathe
out for some reason he comes across
these very angry people who are green
left but here Fox's the green people
because he can jump Luigi hi apparently
people on Mars can jump really high as
well as apparently breathe air this
movie's teaching me so much about Mars
here I thought it's just a location of
Marvin the Martian Abed Tim Burton
movies but it turns out just away from
the green people is another town named
helium and the guards are like princess
the palace is under siege that's not
what people from helium should sound
like they should sound like this so the
bad guy agrees to let everybody live as
long as he just marries the princess and
the king is like hey it's a good plan if
it turned out the only way to end World
War two is then have the President Mary
entler I do it it's almost as possible
as the princess being able to figure out
the secret weapon on the other side when
I'm top scientists camp yes what was you
but the princesses takes it makes it too
Jung Carter and the green people sense
like the title the kids book business
homelessness craziest John Carter on
Mars and the princess is like okay but
I'll need help from a cute little coming
for me so the princess helps him escape
the green people but then the bad guys
catch up with him and he does the most
fiendish thing he can think of he gives
the princess a chance to kill him wait
wait but she doesn't do it wait wait
in fact she decides to marry him wait
what so John Connor is like I thought
you didn't want to marry him
we have taken over dozens of planets
before and watch them destroy themselves
but why because because what we're ball
does Boldin make you really that angry
yes we're very bitter about it but the
Marcin dog helps him escape meet me just
so he can get captured by the green
people again I summon you to fight the
white ape ok he's dead
done I summon you to fight me King me
pray slowly stop the wedding from taking
place that the princess could have
stopped before angels like everybody
this happy ever after except one of the
evil bald guys is like a person who went
to go back to earth says wait wait oh
Christ I'm back on earth I'm gonna wait
10 years to put a plan into motion that
should only take a couple of these and
the bald guy is like but I would have
gotten away with as if it was a vamp st
John Carter oh yeah and that Martian dog
beat me but probably not easy prey
so John Carter was a lot of fun even
though it didn't make sense of that at a
time
but it sure is a great vacation promo
for the planet Mars after this in total
week on I think everybody's gonna go up
there but you do need one thing when you
travel the gaya will yes goodbye James
come on travelling with me to Mars isn't
bad it's gotta be better than watching
Red Planet